men taking selfies is now an “ick”
I don't understand that,
how is men taking selfies an “ick”
I saw a couple videos of people explaining why they think it's an ick
but I don't agree,
in fact, if I like you or wanna pursue you,
I wanna see you.
I want you to share your day with me,
with your selfies or pictures of what you're doing.
I don't think that's an ick
it brightens my day that you wanna share your day with me
the person in this video goes on to explain why they think it's an ick
and they think that it's because
it makes them look like they're too into themselves or too feminine
which I don't agree.
don't you want a man that's confident?
I don't see that as feminine.
especially in the beginning,
like if I like you
I wanna see you and learn more about you and me
send selfie of your outfit of the day,
you at the gym, or what you're doing.
I love that!
it's gonna determine if I like you or if I like your style
now the second explanation that they gave
is that they think that the person is fishing for compliments/
or because he's insecure
so that's what he wants
now men don't necessarily need validation
but it's so important to show interest in him or his life
and if you're not into it
you can still acknowledge that he's interested in it
and it means something to him
that’s basic human decency
so no, I don't think that's cringy or an ick
if a man that you like wants to send you a selfie
or share what they're doing throughout the day
this is the age we're living in
I welcome it, like yes
send me a selfie!
share what you're doing with me!
I love that and I live for that!
I don't know,
call me crazy..
what do you guys think?